imagine you had a monatomic ideal gas in
the cylinder here and there was this
tightly fitted piston above it that
prevented any gas from getting out well
we know that the total internal energy
for a monatomic ideal gas is just
three-halves P times V or three-halves
and Katie or three-halves little n RT
and we know that saying you internal the
internal energy is really just code for
the total kinetic energy of the
monatomic ideal gas that these are the
same thing when we talk about internal
energy we're talking about how fast are
these particles moving in other words
what's the total kinetic energy of all
of these particles added up my question
is how do we go about changing the
internal energy let's say we wanted to
increase the total kinetic energy what
could we do well you could say increase
the pressure or the volume or the
temperature yeah but I mean physically
actually in the lab what do we do and
there's basically two ways to change the
internal energy if you want to add
internal energy ie get these particles
moving faster we can heat it up so put
this above a flame or on a hot plate and
heat will flow into the gas which will
cause these particles to move faster and
faster that's one way to do it to add
heat the other way to do it is to do
work on the gas I could take this piston
and push it down and if you push this
down hard enough it'll squash this gas
together and those impacts with this
piston while it's moving down will cause
them to start moving faster and faster
that will also add internal energy to
the gas so if we wanted to write down a
formula that told us how you could get a
change in the internal energy if I want
to change the internal energy Delta U
which is really just saying changing the
kinetic energy well there's two ways to
do it I can add heat so if I added 10
joules of heat
I'd add 10 joules to the internal energy
but I've also got to take into account
this work being done and so I could do
plus the work done on the gas and that's
it this is actually the first law of
thermodynamics it's a law of
conservation of energy it says there's
only two ways to add
internal energy to a gas let me talk a
little bit more about this work done
though because getting the sign rights
important if you're doing work on the
gas compressing it you're adding energy
to the gas but if you let the gas push
up on the piston and this gas expands
pushing the piston up then the gas is
doing work that's energy leaving the
system so if the gas does work you have
to subtract work done by the gas if the
outside force does work on the gas you
add that to the internal energy so
you've got to pay attention to which way
the energy is flowing work done on gas
energy goes in work done by the gas
energy goes out and you'd have to
subtract that over here let's say the
gas did expand let's say the gas in here
was under so much pressure that the
force it exerted on this piston was
enough to push that piston upward by a
certain amount so let's say that started
right here and it went up to here so
that piston went from here to there no
gas is escaping because this is tightly
fitting but the gas was able to push it
up a certain distance D how much work
was done you know the definition of work
work is defined to be the force times
the distance through which that force
was applied so the work that the gas did
was F times D but we want this to be in
terms of thermal quantities like
pressure and volume and temperature so
what could we do we can say that this
volume not only did the piston raise up
that there was an extra volume generated
within here that I'm going to call Delta
V and I know that this Delta V has got
to equal the area of the piston times
the distance through which that piston
moved because this height times that
area gives me this volume right in here
why am i doing this because look I can
write D as equal to Delta V over a and I
can take this and I can substitute this
formula for D into here and something
magical happens I'll get work equals F
times Delta V over a but look F over a
we know what F over a is that's pressure
so I get that the work done by the gas
is the pressure times Delta V this is an
equation that I like because it's in
terms of
quantities that we're already dealing
with so work done you can figure out by
taking P times Delta V but strictly
speaking this is only true if this
pressure remained constant right if the
pressure was changing then what am I
supposed to plug in here the initial
pressure the final pressure if the
pressure staying constant this gives you
an exact way to find the work done you
might object and say wait how's it
possible for a gas to expand and remain
at the same pressure well you basically
have to heat it up while the gas expands
that allows the pressure to remain
constant as the gas expands and now
we're finally ready to talk about heat
capacity so let's get rid of this and
heat capacity is defined to be imagine
you had a certain amount of heat being
added so a certain amount of heat gets
added to your gas how much does the
temperature increase that's what the
heat capacity tells you so capital C is
heat capacity and it's a defined B the
amount of heat that you've added to the
gas divided by the amount of change in
the temperature of that gas and actually
something you'll hear about often is the
molar heat capacity which is actually
divided by an extra n here so instead of
Q over delta T it's Q over and the
number of moles times delta T pretty
simple but think about it if we had a
piston in here are we going to allow
that piston to move while we add the
heat or are we not going to allow the
piston to move there's different ways
that this can happen and because of that
there's different heat capacities if we
don't allow this piston to move if we
weld this thing shut so it can't move
we've got heat capacity at constant
volume and if we do allow this piston to
move freely while we add the heat so
that the pressure inside of here remains
constant we'd have the heat capacity at
constant pressure and these are similar
but different and they're related and we
can figure them out so let's clear this
away let's get up nice here we go two
Pistons inside of cylinders we'll put a
piston in here but I'm going to weld
this one shut this one can't move we'll
have another one over here they can move
freely over on this side we'll have the
definition of heat capacity regular heat
capacity is the amount
heat you add / the change in temperature
that you get so on this side we're
adding heat let's say heat goes in but
the piston does not move and so the gas
in here is stuck it can't move no work
can be done since this piston can't move
external forces can't do work on the gas
and the gas can't do work and allow
energy to leave q is the only thing
adding energy into the system or in
other words we've got heat capacity at
constant volume is going to equal well
remember the first law of thermodynamics
said that Delta U the only way to add
internal energy or take it away is that
you can add or subtract heat and you can
do work on the gas in this case Q if I
subtract W from both sides I'd get Delta
U minus W over delta T but since we're
not allowing this piston to move the
work done has got to be zero so there's
no work done at all so the heat capacity
at constant volume is going to be Delta
U over delta T what's Delta U let's just
assume this is a monatomic ideal gas if
it's monatomic we've got a formula for
this Delta U is just three-halves P
times V over delta T that's not the only
way I can write it remember I can also
write it as 3 halves + K delta T over
delta T and something magical happens
check it out the Delta T's go away and
you get that this is a constant that the
heat capacity for any monatomic ideal
gas is just going to be three-halves
Capital n K Boltzmann constant and is
the total number of molecules or you
could have rewrote this as little an R
delta T the T's would still have
canceled and you would have got
three-halves little n the number of
moles times R the gas constant so the
heat capacity at constant volume for any
monatomic ideal gas is just three-halves
NR and if you wanted the molar heat
capacity remember that's just divided by
an extra mole here so everything gets
divided by moles everywhere divided by
moles that just cancels the
Seau and the molar heat capacity at
constant volume is just three-halves r
so that's heat capacity at constant
volume
what about heat capacity at constant
pressure now we're going to look at this
side again we're going to allow this gas
to have heat enter the cylinder but
we're going to allow this piston to move
up while it does that so that the
pressure inside of here remains constant
and this is going to be the heat
capacity at constant pressure well again
we're going to get that it's Q over
delta T and just like the first law said
Q has to equal Delta u minus W so we get
Delta u minus W the work done over delta
T this time W is not zero
what's W going to be remember W is P
times Delta V so this is a way we can
find the work done by the gas P times
Delta V so this is going to equal Delta
U we know that is if this is again a
monatomic ideal gas this is going to
equal three halves n our delta T plus
this is P times Delta V but we have to
be careful in this formula this work is
referring to work done on the gas but in
this case work is being done by the gas
so I need another negative technically
the work done on the gas would be a
negative amount of this since energy is
leaving the system so that negative
cancels this negative and I get plus P
times Delta V all of that over delta T
so what do we get three halves n R delta
T plus I want to rewrite P times Delta V
but I know how to do that the ideal gas
law says PV equals NRT well if that's
true then P times Delta V is going to
equal an R delta T so I can rewrite this
as an R delta T divided by delta T
almost there all the Delta T's go away
and the go to I'm left with I'm left
with C heat capacity at constant
pressure is going to be equal to
three-halves NR plus NR
that's just five halves and our and if I
wanted the molar heat capacity again I
could divide everything everything
around here by little n and that would
just give me the molar heat capacity
constant pressure would be five halves
are and notice they're almost the same
the heat capacity at constant volume is
three halves n R and the heat capacity
at constant pressure is five halves n R
they just differ by n R so the
difference between the heat capacity at
constant volume which is three halves
and R and the heat capacity at constant
pressure which is five halves n R is
just CP minus CV which is n R just n R
and if you wanted to take the difference
between the molar heat capacities at
constant volume and pressure it would
just be R the difference would just be R
because everything would get divided by
the number of moles so there's a
relationship an important relationship
that tells you the difference between
the heat capacity at constant pressure
and the heat capacity at constant volume